i went to the justin bieber show yeah
yeah
i mean as a performance
it was incredible you're like front row
like spit in my mouth daddy sweat on me
let me be the one last lonely girl come
on
dude it was so funny
it was like uh oh who's telling me i
think it was matt was telling me like
in the one of the justin bieber like
documentaries or whatever it was some
girl that was like
she they interviewed her and she had
like gone to get her braces off or
something
just in case justin bieber were to pull
her butt pull her up on stage
and she ended up being in the very last
row of the stadium
it's
horrible
wow they're like
so what'd you do for justin how excited
were you for the show and she's like
yeah i just you know years of having
braces and just got to remove for him oh
god dude so the show was really good
like
performance wise he's [ __ ] incredible
like his voice is amazing it's one of
the best live voices i've ever heard
yeah
um and he like did sings without a
backing track the whole time wow
and uh still does this kind of like
choreography sometimes or whatever but
like the funniest part is that he's
still kind of stuck in his
like fuckboy
pop star persona where he does he used
to stop the performance in the middle
and give a long monologue about how the
world is super divided it honestly
sounded like knock it off
i'm serious
it's like we're in this period of
literal war in europe and he's like
just like
wish everyone would get along you know
everyone in the stadium [ __ ] yeah
that's [ __ ]
so funny it's so funny
yeah they can and also
racism is like pretty whack
he said that no no he didn't say that
but like that's right that's honestly
the speech kind of sounded like that
but just was kind of
didn't really say anything really yeah
introspective yeah he's just kind of
like yeah bad things suck
and war is bad and we should take the
time to like
look at each other yeah
and like top each other up
wow
you know what i mean yeah
yeah
sorry
yo
[ __ ] just oh
we should not grant ukraine
a no-fly zone
because that would be like world war
three
we should just chill instead
and that's what inspired us next song
he stops the show in the middle of what
do you mean yeah well do you hear me
wait i got to say something real quick
i think if putin
and zielinski
just like smoked a spliff together
oh god
oh god
[Laughter]
i'm your front row justin don't do it
just shut the [ __ ] up
keep the song going move on
just sing [ __ ]
that's what you want to do just sing
cut all that other [ __ ] out he said that
too in the middle of the speech he was
like now i know y'all hear from my voice
or whatever
yes we are don't do this
we have twitter man we don't need this
from you just stop no more i know y'all
here to hear me sing but like i gotta
take this bashful second and just make a
statement
no
someone's shooting themselves
in the audience oh my god
nah but justin if you're watching this
on block me dog
i went to your show he still hasn't been
blocked how did you think of a [ __ ] move
is that yeah you
might be on my part you paid money to
see a guy who has you blocked
that is horrible
objectively i'm a fan of his i love his
[ __ ] i love his music it was like a
[ __ ] 90 minutes straight of great
music yeah with just two minutes of like
oh no yeah yeah
you gotta throw it in there yeah
yeah i think people should stop crying
real talk
now there's a war going on right there
[Laughter]
but russia i feel like there's just one
word that you can learn how to use
is it too late now to say sorry
your body
wouldn't hear me out man
[Laughter]
oh my god
[Laughter]
putin hear me out dog
oh my god
[ __ ] you know i'm glad you went man
you brought that to us today yeah
are you watching this speech like i
can't wait for [ __ ] tuesday oh my god
i love that feeling when you see some
crazy ass [ __ ] you're like
yeah tuesday's gonna be an episode yeah
yeah yeah
thank you bro
you know what's crazier
you're like one of nine people that left
that arena that was like that was
[ __ ] weird
everyone else was like that [ __ ] like
oh my god that speech game was so
powerful
that's honestly what we we as a nation
need to hear you know
he just has such good messaging we are
divided and i didn't fully realize it
until i went to the show tonight then
some like ugly guy in the car says like
yo i totally agree shut the [ __ ] up zach
sorry zack
our producer's like what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] did i do
the [ __ ] did i do
you